this is Pixar studios I'm sure almost
everyone's heard of them and watch their
movies they've they've won a few awards
along the way too but less people
realize just how much mathematics and
science goes into animating these films
even the boss here is a computer
scientist this is Tony DeRose and he
leads the research group at Pixar and
today he's talking to us here at
numberphile well my particular area of
interest is in in geometric modelling
creating shapes of things and that
problem comes up a lot around here
because we've got characters with you
know pretty complicated shapes you know
some of the characters on the board
behind me this is a this is a sculpture
of the hand of Jerry from Jerry's game a
character in a short film that we did
quite a few years ago now and it you
know just it's a complicated shape and
we needed to develop some way of
representing these kinds of shapes in a
way that artists could deal with but
computers could could render and display
quickly as well so yawn pink Allah the
director of Jerry's game was also a
sculptor so he created this sculpture of
Jerry's hand and then we later digitized
it and made the final surface that
appeared on the screen let's simplify
first and we'll get back to surfaces in
three dimensions in a minute but let's
start say with curves in two dimensions
to explain the basics of the process so
what I've got here is a little
four-point polygon and it's going to be
my job to make a smooth curve out of it
I'm going to make a smooth curve out of
it by just repeating a few simple steps
so the first step I'm going to call
split and what that does is it adds
midpoints to the edges so now I've got
eight points but it's not really any
smoother the next thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to make it a little bit
smoother by repositioning all eight of
these points so this guy for instance is
going to move where he is now to the
midpoint of his right neighbor
similarly this guy is going to move to
his right neighbor and let me animate
that for you I'll call that the
averaging step so now we've got eight
points a little bit smoother
and again my goal is to make a smooth
curve and so I'm just going to repeat
I'm going to split an average so now
I've got 16 points again a little bit
smoother I'll put those two steps into a
combined step I'll call subdivide and
you see that as I continue to subdivide
the smooth curve starts to emerge and
that's the basis of how we create all of
our surfaces this splitting and
averaging idea also works for surfaces
so here's an example where I start with
a cube so if I split it's a little more
complicated for surfaces to split I have
to insert edge midpoints like this one
here like I did for curves and I also
have to introduce the middles of faces
but again that's just done by averaging
so this point here is just the average
of the four points around it and then I
average in this case I need to use a
carefully constructed weighted average
for reasons we may talk about in a
minute but if I pick my averaging
weights carefully enough I can continue
this split in average process and
generate smooth surfaces in the limit
and that's exactly how Gerry's hand and
in fact Gerry himself was built well
here for instance are the points that we
digitized off this sculpture before
subdivision we run this splitting and
averaging process a lot of times and
that smoothes the surface out and
creates the smooth shape that you
ultimately see on the screen to the
untrained person which I very much am
this seam is sort of it doesn't seem
very subtle it seems like anything you
feed into this process will just kind of
get bla bhai's din the same way
everything will get turned into this
kind of generic blob is there is there
more nuance to this the model than what
it looks like what does everything turn
into a big blur well if there is some
nuance there's some magic numbers
involved so let's get a sense of what
those numbers are one pair of magic
numbers are one one here those are the
weights that I used in this averaging
step when I move things to midpoints and
those are magic because you can show
that a nice thing happens in the limit
of this subdivision so this one one
means it's going to go to a spot that is
one part of where he is now
and one part of where his right neighbor
is now okay so let's do that let's let's
each stage is split followed by average
so there's the split so when he moves
according to the one wrote one rule he's
going to move from where he is now to
here and this guy's going to move from
where he is now to here and so on so
we'll see that and we just keep
repeating that process and a beautiful
thing happens in the limit you can show
that this curve is a there's a parabolic
arc that sits in here and there's
another parabolic arc that sits in here
and those two parabolic arcs meet with a
smooth derivative a smooth tangent line
at this point and that's all just an
emergent property of this subdivision
process there are some other magic
numbers I can use for instance if I use
one-to-one so I split as before now if
we use the one-to-one rule this guy is
going to move from where he is now to
two parts of where he is now one part of
his left neighbor and one part of his
right neighbor so it was anyone so he's
carrying more of his white yeah exactly
and so if I average with that set of
weights I get a shape like this I
continue to split an average again
something really nice happens when we
use the one one rule we got piecewise
parabolas which are degree two curves
here we're going to get degree three
curves in the limit and if I pick
weights one three three one and do this
process it turns out you get degree four
curves and this pattern is I think
probably familiar to many of your
viewers 1 1 1 2 1 1 3 3 1 those are all
rows of something called Pascal's
triangle so what we're learning here is
that if you pick your weights carefully
that is from rows of Pascal's triangle
the curves that you get and limit are
nice and smooth and they're polynomials
and the degree of the polynomial is
given by how deep into Pascal's triangle
you pick your weights but you don't have
to pick them carefully you don't have to
pick your weights carefully I can in
fact I don't even have to make the way
it's positive so suppose I pick rates 1
-2 and 3 so I split as before
now this guy is going to go to a point
which is minus one times himself one
times is left neighbour and three times
is right neighborhood no idea what's
going to happen yeah let's see what
happens okay
something interesting let's continue
we'll keep doing that so what we're
seeing here is in the limit if you don't
pick your weights carefully you get
something that isn't smooth anywhere in
fact it's a fractal so we're gonna watch
one of your films which one is the right
one which one creates two surfaces that
make you happy well it turns out that
four surfaces this Pascal's triangle
pattern doesn't work anymore you have to
use a different set of mathematical
tools to figure out weights that are
going to generate smooth objects and
limit and those are very carefully
chosen weights they were first
discovered by Ed Catmull 40 years ago
Ed's the president of Pixar do we know
those like are they like like fractions
are they what numbers are there they
like one one point seven and three point
nine two well I don't remember them off
the top of my head but there's a simple
formula that is now well known you can
find it on our website so when you've
got your 3d object they're the they're
the ones you plug in and then bang yeah
exactly so what I was doing the
subdivision with the cube we were using
those very carefully constructed weights
that had discovered we do this
subdivision process a few times and it
that gets his points that are kind of
close to where they would go if we did
in an infinite number of times but on
top of that there's a few tricks that we
use to figure out exactly where they're
going to go mathematically we we think
about what would happen if we did it an
infinite number of times and it turns
out that we can write down exactly what
happens if we did do it an infinite
number of times it's quick yeah so let's
see how that works
and let's start with an observation here
okay so I'm going to go back to the
simple 1 1 rule that we had earlier and
watch what happens on say this leg of
the polygon so I'm going to split an
average
and notice that what happened here is
that I still have two points on this
polygon leg they're just a little bit
closer if I split an average again again
I get two points on this leg they're
just a little closer together if I do it
again again they're closer so what's
going to happen if I do this an infinite
number of times well these two points
are going to get closer and closer
together in the limit
they'll be on top of each other and the
location where they converge is the
midpoint of the original leg so without
doing any computation at all I can
determine very quickly that these four
blue points are on that limit object and
the nice thing about that observation is
that it holds at every stage of
subdivision watch what happens on this
leg of the polygon so this leg wasn't in
my original arrangement but it got
introduced after the first stage and as
I split an average we're going to again
see two points on this same line they
just get closer and closer together as I
subdivide and again they're going to
converge to the midpoint of the leg when
it was first introduced so let's go back
to that arrangement here so I know that
the midpoint of this leg is also on the
limit object so after one stage of
subdivision I already know eight points
exactly that you refer to this thing
called the limit object that's the
finished product that's the finished
product right so it's the mathematically
perfect version and now I've got eight
points that are on the mathematically
perfect curve computing what happens in
the limit becomes a little bit more
delicate when we look at one of these
other rules like the one-to-one rule so
let's see if we can track where this
point goes as I subdivide that way using
a one-to-one now this is a one-to-one
rule so if I split an average okay so he
moved some distance let me split an
average again he's moved a little bit
more it's not exactly clear where he's
going to stop he's not only my object
he's not a living object yet so but yet
we can compute exactly where he's going
to go with some other magic numbers
let's take a look at how that worked I
draw a little pieces my Curt my original
polygon and since this is my original
polygon I'm going to use superscript
zeros so a is super zero be super zero
and see super zero so that's before
subdivision if I subdivide once I get
some points that are going to sit in
here and I'm going to call this guy a
super one be super one and see super one
and if I subdivide it again I get some
more points in here and what we want to
know is
okay here's B zero here's B 1 B 2 is
going to be someplace the question is
where is B infinity
we'd like to figure out where that is
turns out we can answer that question
and to do that I'm going to write down a
few things I know well one thing I know
is that a super one is just on this
midpoint so I could write that as a plus
B over two and these are super zero guys
my original things if you work out the
algebra of the splitting and averaging
using the one to one rule you can see
that be super one is a super zero plus
six be super zero plus C super zero
divided by eight so that's just
unwinding the split and average process
and then C super 1 again is just the
midpoint on this leg so that's B super
zero plus C super zero over 2 ok well
that isn't obviously helping us answer
the question of where B infinity is to
do that I'm going to do something a
little bit sneaky take a super zero and
be super zero and C super zero and
combine them with weights one four and
one and we'll have to divide by 6
put one there because I have kind of six
things in the numerator what are the one
for one
my back pocket and you'll see why I
picked one for one in just a second
the real answer is it came from a tool
called eigen analysis but we don't need
I get analysis to see what's going to
happen here I'm going to take that same
combination and apply it to a super one
be super one and see super one so I get
four be super one one copy of a super
one one copy of C super one and divided
by six so now I have two expressions and
if you take these equations over here
and just substitute them in here and
simplify what you'll see is this
expression is actually equal to this
expression and it's only true for these
weights one for one and the cool thing
is that I can use that same reasoning to
figure out that going from the one the
super one condition to the twice
subdivided condition again applying one
for one to the twice subdivided points
over six I could I'll find that these
two expressions are also equal so I can
repeat this process any number of times
I like say all the way to infinity so I
can compute a infinity for B infinity
plus C infinity over six and that's
still going to be equal to the
expression that I had to start with and
now the beautiful thing happens if you
think about what happens to this little
arrangement of three points as you
continue to subdivide those three points
on this on the second stage get closer
together the third stage even closer is
I do it an infinite number of times all
three of those points converge to this
place be infinity so these are all B
infinities actually so this turns into B
infinity infinity and B infinity are the
same in the limit C infinity and B
infinity are the same so I can rewrite
this as B and fattie plus 4b infinity
plus B infinity
/ 6 well averaging together a bunch of B
infinity is just gives me B infinity and
so what I've learned is that V infinity
is right there I start with my original
points take them with weight 1 for 1 and
that gives me the Infinity straightaway
exactly in no approximation before you
even started you knew where he was going
to end up exactly so if I take some
other polygon now I know that B infinity
is going to be for parts of this guy 1
part of this guy and 1 part of this guy
which is going to be a point about right
there and again that can be computed
without approximation if I had say the 1
3 3 1 rule I'd get a slightly different
set of expressions here and get a
different collection of magic numbers
again solved for with a systematic tool
called eigen analysis and it would have
this same property and the whole thing
works for 3d as well for surfaces right
and so that lets us compute exact points
on the surfaces of our characters and we
can even compute exact derivatives which
we need for computing that nice smooth
gradation in illumination or shading in
the graphics we'll have more from this
interview with Tony coming very soon and
that will be uploaded to our sister
channel computer file so go over there
and keep an eye out for that one well
films that I've worked closely on it's
hard to watch and not see all the files